up Strider I recently moved to a new
city for work but you know I miss my
family I'm a little homesick you got any
tips what I would do bro if I was you is
take the time to craft a handwritten
letter and then here's the thing when
your family receives that letter
immediately they're going to be worried
about you you're going to worry people
by sending handwritten letters and make
yourself feel better so that's chill you
are then saving Dough because they're
hopping on a flight to see you and be
like is everything okay and then you're
like oh yeah it's a little homesick I
just wanted to craft a nice letter it's
pretty sick I'm glad you guys got it you
could have just written back but now
you're posting up sipping coffees
hitting museums tasting a little bit of
Home in your new town